-I want to talk about "Ant-Man,"
'cause I'm very
excited about this.
But I've known you
for a long time.
I feel like I know
a lot of things about you.
I did not know this, that you
are a co-owner of a candy shop.
-Yes.
-This is not a joke.
I am co-owner of a candy store
called Samuel's Sweet Shop,
in Rhinebeck, New York.
-Okay.
-And I own this candy store
with Jeffrey Dean Morgan.
-Who's a fantastic actor.
-Great actor.
Plays Negan
on "The Walking Dead."
-"Walking Dead," yeah.
-And another guy
named Andy Ostroy.
We all kind of
live around there.
And we --
I brought you something.
-Okay.
I'm so excited.
-So, we have lots of old...
-Old candy.
-...kind of fun candy.
-Great.
-And then, there's another --
There's a woman
named Donna Weber
who makes these treats for us.
And she was so nice to put
my face on a Rice Krispie treat.
-Yeah. Right over there.
[ Laughter ]
Or Jeff on a Rice Krispie treat.
-Okay, there you go.
So there you go.
There's Jeffrey.
All right, so --
-And then, there's Andy,
who you can see,
he's not really famous.
He's just the other guy.
-Okay, go over there, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
-And they don't really
sell that much,
so I brought you
a bunch of Andy's.
-Okay, got it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
And, um...
You can tell --
Here, give it a shot.
Andy is delicious.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Um, now, do people,
when they first see it,
because he's next
to you and Jeffrey,
do they go, "What's he in?"
They must assume he's an actor.
-Uh, I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
But...
-Is he delicious?
-He's delicious!
-Now, quality-wise --
-I'm gonna take a bite out of
Andy and a sip out of you.
[ Laughter ]
-I've never heard anybody --
Thank you so much.
So -- So this is your second
"Ant-Man" film.
Where does this one pick up?
-Well, after --
Oh, wow.
Now I've got Andy
caught in my teeth.
-Yeah, that was a mistake.
-I'll keep that joke going.
It picks up,
I'm under house arrest,
because if you remember at
the end of the "Civil War"...
-Mm-hmm.
-...all the Avengers
are fighting,
and then, I get caught, and
I get put under house arrest.
-Right.
-That is why
I'm not in "Infinity War."
People have asked me.
-'Cause your character
was under house arrest.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And they couldn't --
They couldn't plot you
out of house arrest?
In all the things
that they figure ways out of
in a Marvel universe...
-Well, no,
he's got to stay inside.
[ Laughter ]
But, uh, yes,
I'm under house arrest,
and I've kind of put
Hank and Hope --
they're not talking to me,
it's --
We're a little bit at odds.
-So, this is interesting,
'cause you co-wrote this script.
-Right.
-Now, I have a lot of people
who are stars
of the Marvel films here,
and a lot of times,
they are limited by, of course,
what they can say,
and, also, they're limited
by design as far as knowing
what's gonna happen next
in the universe.
Did you have to get more
information than most of them
because you were actually
working on the script?
-Yeah.
And it's terrifying to know --
to have these secrets,
to know some of these things.
I feel a lot of pressure.
-Mm-hmm.
-But I also feel very
privileged, because, like,
I knew about that "Infinity War"
before it was gonna happen.
-You knew
you weren't gonna be in it?
[ Laughter ]
-I knew --
By the way, people say,
"infinity War,"
I go, "I guess we'll see."
It's like,
"I know I'm not in it."
[ Laughter ]
However -- However, people
have asked me about this one,
and, uh...this --
I don't know if I'm supposed
to say this, but I'll say it.
It happens kind of concurrently.
-Got it.
-And it's very important,
because it doesn't exist
in a vacuum.
You have to stay
through the end,
because when you see this thing,
through those
post-credit scenes,
there's some
mind-blowing stuff in there
that kind of
ties into "Infinity War."
And it's --
I think I messed up.
-You think you mess--
I think --
[ Applause ]
I don't know how
that could mess up, though,
because I would only think
that would make more people
see the movie,
which I feel like's the endgame.
-You know what?
You're right.
[ Laughter ]